well sources are telling us that
President Biden is planning to visit
Southern Nevada next week those sources
say the president will be here March
15th in order to officially designate
Avi Kwame as a National Monument now the
designation would protect about 450
000 acres of land from ever being
developed today in a tweet Democratic
senator I should say Deena Titus
congresswoman are writing quote tribal
leaders conservationists and local
officials have pushed to designate
abiquame as a National Monument for over
20 years I worked alongside them to lead
that fight in Congress now the sacred
land will finally be protected for
future Generations